[Music]
In this problem, a water sample has the
following composition given in the table
provided. Based on the difference
between the sum of the cations ions and
the sum of the annions in miller
equivalents per liter, is the water
electrically balanced or should the
sample be reviewed again? Our options
are yes, the water is balanced, no the
cations ions are higher, no the annions
are higher or not enough information.
So in this video, we're going to
calculate the difference between the sum
of the cations ions and the sum of the
annions in a water
sample. We're given the concentrations
of several ions in mg per liter. That's
mg over l. And our job is to convert
those into mill equivalents per liter or
meq l so that we can compare the total
positive charges the cations ions with
the total negative charges the
annions. Since the problem is asking for
the difference between the sum of the
cations and annions, we are in the realm
of a charge balance problem. That means
that we should be expressing all of our
ions in mill equivalents per liter as
noted by the
problem and we should be using the
equivalence weights based on the ionic
charge. In other words, this is not a
problem where we are going to be using
redux electrons or redux reactions. To
solve this problem, you could go to the
periodic
table in the reference manual to get
some of the information that you might
need about each chemical. Page 30 of the
reference manual also has data on
selected elements, radicals, and
compounds. In this case, the atomic
weight and the equivalent weight for
some of the chemicals that we're going
to be solving for in our problem. Rather
than use the equivalent weight directly
from page 30, we're going to find the
equivalent weight based on the atomic
weight and the charge of the electron.
So that no matter what chemical is
given, you'll be able to solve it on the
exam. So we can see here that we've got
sodium, calcium, and magnesium all with
positive charged electrons. These are
going to be our cations ions.
We then have chloride, sulfate, nitrate
expressed as nitrogen and alkalinity
expressed as Ca3 or calcium
carbonate. These are what we need to
solve our problem. The BOD5, the
dissolved organic carbon and the algae
count are extraneous information and
just here to confuse you. So let's start
by converting each concentration to a
mill equivalent per liter.
The formula for mill equivalent per
liter is going to be mg per liter
divided by the equivalent weight of each
chemical. The equivalent weight is going
to be found by dividing the molar mass
by the electron
charge. So let's first create a column
up here for atomic
weight and then we can fill this in
below. Sodium has an atomic weight of
23. Calcium has an atomic weight of
40.1. Magnesium has an atomic weight of
24.3. Chloride has an atomic weight of
35.5. Sulfate has an atomic weight of
96. The nitrate expressed as nitrogen
has an atomic weight in nitrogen of 14.
And the alkalinity expressed as Caic has
an atomic weight of
100. Now we look at the electron
charges.
Sodium has a charge of
+1. Calcium has a charge of +2.
Magnesium has a charge of +2. Chloride
has a charge of -1. Sulfate has a charge
of
-2. Nitrate expressed as nitrogen has a
charge of -1 and the alkalinity will
have
a charge of -2.
Alkalinity might be confusing to you
since it's not just a single annion. I
will elaborate more about the charge for
this at the end of the
video. Now, this lets us calculate our
equivalent
weights. So, 23 / 1 is 23. 40.1 / 2 is
20.5.
/ 24.3 / 2 is
12.15. 35.5 / 1 is
35.5. 96 / 2 is 48. 14 / 1 is 14 and 100
/ 2 is 50. Again, some of these
equivalent weights will be present on
page 30. If these are all you need and
you don't have time to calculate them.
Now that we have everything we need to
solve this problem, we can calculate the
cations ions in their miller equivalents
per liter and then do the same for the
annions and compare
them. So over here we will sum the
cations
ions. Sodium is going to be from our
table 23 mg per liter divided by 23
equivalents per millig.
Calcium will be 40 /
20.05. Magnesium will be 12 /
12.15 to give us
0.99. Summing these three up give us a
total cation mill equivalent per liter
of
four. If we do the same thing for the
annions, we can see
that chloride is 35 mg per liter from
the table divided by 35.5 mg per mill
equivalent or mill equivalents per
millig. Nitrate as nitrogen will be 14 /
14 to get 1.
Sulfate will be 48 divided by 48 to get
one and Ca3 will be 150 / 50 to get
three. If we sum up these four annions,
we can get six mill equivalents per
liter for the annions.
What this shows us is that we have more
annions than cations ions. So no, the
water is not electrically
balanced. Now let's go back to that note
about alkalinity in
water.
Ca3 breaks down to
Ca2+ plus CO3 minus
2. Ca2+ is a cation. That's going to
contribute to hardness and not
alkalinity.
CO3 minus 2 is what contributes to the
annions. This is the part that is
responsible for the
alkalinity. The charge on this chemical
is what
corresponds in our table over here to
the charge of two or the charge of -2.
So when we are expressing alkalinity as
Ca3 the only charge that matters will be
the one for the annions here. Alkalinity
is just the equivalent of the annion
charge just from the CO3
minus2. The reason this is done
sometimes is that alkalinity is treated
as an equivalent of an annion charge
although it's not a single chemical
species. So that's it. We've walked
through the full process of finding the
atomic weights, identifying the charge
numbers, and then finding the equivalent
weights so that we could divide the mg
per liter by the equivalents per
milligram to get our final sums of our
cations and annions in this problem. And
that's it.